on Marseilles estate's trouble is
simmering here shootings are frequent
and cannabis and cocaine provide a
steady income
our guide I mean knows how dangerous it
can be his brother fell into drugs and
was murdered are there lots of
um
drug dealers on this estate yes the dog
dealers in this place but not in this
building
neglected for decades public transports
limited so too a jobs education and
opportunities
you have a sixth apartment on the one
floors and it's a six family it's a very
small yes very small for this all
families and this Creator
anger yes anger people
is not happy
I mean thinks that isolation and
frustration helped fuel the recent
rioting and looting after police shot
teenager Nile
at first it was all Justice for Nile but
now they don't even know what they're
fighting for it's all sorts of things
that are mixed up France is like a
pressure cooker we've added and added
and added to it put on the lid and then
the lid is blown off
extreme poverty pumps up the pressure
youth unemployment here can reach 70
percent
so when order broke down some saw an
opportunity
I think that since everyone is breaking
everything they're making the most of it
to go looting says I mean sister-in-law
Tamara uh police proximity police aren't
a deterrent the police Hut is long
closed the shooting of Nile has
Amplified complaints about racist
officers as many here share his North
African Heritage and feel targeted
something unions deny
the problem there may be some problems
on the margins I stress on the margins a
sort of residual discrimination maybe
but it's not proven today the police
really is a mirror image of the
population
the government's brought in extra police
to restore calm
cracking down on troublemakers
but I mean believes any peace will be
short-lived
we can't call for calm for people who
don't have anything else to lose that's
it really these days half of these kids
don't have anything to lose when they're
arrested taken to jail killed they don't
really have a life so it won't make a
difference
the president has pledged extra money to
boost the area extra police to keep
order
but the riots have revealed a fracture
within France healing it begins on its
forgotten Estates
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Marseille